Alors aujourd’hui on va parler du stoïcisme
Bon donc le stoïcisme c’est un gros morceau
ça correspond à la période de l’antiquité, on est au troisième siècle avant Jésus Christ
Donc c’est un mouvement philosophique qui vient après Socrate, Platon, Aristote
Et c’est un mouvement qui a perduré à travers les siècles, qui a subi pas mal d’évolutions voire de déformations
Alors c’est toujours difficile d’aborder un grand courant philosophique comme celui là
parce que la question c’est de savoir par quel bout le prendre
Et le problème se pose d’autant plus que le stoïcisme correspond à ce qu’on pourrait appeler à une philosophie totale
Philosophie totale, c'est-à-dire que ce n’est pas seulement un système de pensée,
un système de compréhension du monde
C’est à la fois une philosophie théorique, et une philosophie pratique
C’est une philosophie qui est tournée à la fois vers la compréhension mais aussi vers l’action
Vers l’action dans le monde et qui est donc destinée à l’individu.
Alors on va à partir de quelques citations, je donnerai des citations de mémoire parce que je n’ai pas préparé là cette vidéo
Je préfère improviser, donner des pistes et puis ensuite chacun prend ce qu’il à envie de prendre et poursuit ses recherches.
Alors je vais partir d’une première citation
à laquelle on fait souvent référence pour résumer le stoïcisme
qui est de dire il y a ce qui dépend de nous, il y a ce qui ne dépend pas de nous
Donc la a vision stoïcienne du monde elle est déjà basée sur une première séparation
une séparation dont on doit prendre conscience
pour comprendre nos limites, nos limites en tant qu’être humain et nos limites en tant qu’individu
Il y a des choses qui dépendent de nous par exemple
il dépend de moi de travailler pour réussir
il dépend de moi de rechercher la vérité
il dépend de moi de bien agir
il ne dépend pas de moi d’être grand, fort, puissant
il ne dépend pas de moi d’être beau, il ne dépend pas de moi de naitre à tel ou tel endroit
donc on arrive assez bien à comprendre en fait ce que nous disent les stoïciens
il y a ce dont on hérite
et il y a ce qu’on construit par soit même
Evidemment on pourra toujours répondre que cette limite est assez floue
Par exemple les stoïciens disent qu’il ne dépend pas de nous d’être riche
or on peut faire remarquer que bien si il dépend de nous d’être riche
c'est-à-dire que bien si je dirige mon action vers la réussite matérielle, financière
j’ai plus de chance d’être riche que si je ne fais rien
Donc en ce sens on pourra toujours trouver
des points de détails sur lesquels
ces divisions entre ce qui dépend de nous et ce qui ne dépend pas de nous
est discutable mais dans les grandes lignes encore une fois on comprend ce que ça veut dire
Prendre conscience de cette distinction entre ce qui dépend de nous et ce qui ne dépend pas de nous
en fait pour les stoïciens c’est juste un premier pas
C’est le premier pas vers la conscience que nous ne sommes pas en capacité de tout faire
et que nous sommes fondamentalement limités
Donc de ce point de vue là la philosophie stoïcienne c’est un appel à l’humilité
L’humilité qui n’est rien d’autre que la reconnaissance de notre impuissance, de notre finitude
On peut le dire de manière inversée, si
j’ai des souhaits, ou des désirs ou des ambitions totalement démesurées
d’une manière ou d’une autre je vais être confronté à mes limites. Je ne vais pas pouvoir accéder à tout ce que je souhaite
et lorsque je rencontrerai des obstacles à mes désirs
bien le problème c’est que je risque d’être malheureux
Pour le dire de manière synthétique
si je désire des choses impossibles
je vais souffrir
Je vais souffrir parce que je vais m’en rendre compte que
par définition ce qui est impossible ne m’est pas accessible
Alors ça à l’air totalement évident et banal de dire ça, on peut se dire mais
c’est vraiment ça de la philosophie, dire que ce qui est impossible est impossible, en quelque sorte c’est une tautologie
oui mais
si les stoïciens prennent la peine de le préciser c’est parce que dans notre comportement quotidien, dans notre comportement réel, on a tendance à l’oublier
On a tendance à croire que certaines choses peuvent dépendent de nous alors qu’elles n’en dépendent pas
Et ils prennent quelques exemples très concrets
Premier exemple
je sais, j’ai conscience que
ma vie est limitée, mon existence sur cette terre est limitée dans le temps
et d’ailleurs l’existence de tous les êtres humains est limitée, donc
lorsque quelqu’un meurt
et bien même si c’est quelqu’un à qui je tenais beaucoup
même si quelqu’un que j’aimais
je dois accepter sa disparition, je dois accepter la mort de cette personne puisque que
c’est dans l’essence de l’être humain de naître, de vivre et de mourir
Etre triste parce que un être cher meurt, pour les stoïciens c’est d’abord une aberration logique,
et c’est vrai c’est une aberration logique
Je ne peux pas faire en sorte que les gens que j’aime soient éternels, c’est un fait
donc cette première limite de la nature humaine qui est la mort donc la limite temporelle
bien je dois pas seulement savoir qu’elle existe mais je dois l’accepter
Et c’est là qu’on voit que chez les stoïciens
comprendre quelque chose, avoir conscience de quelque chose
c’est pas simplement savoir que ça existe
c’est l’accepter au plus profond de son être et même au plus profond de sa chair
Et c’est à ce moment là qu’on s’aperçoit que la philosophie stoïcienne n’est pas qu’une philosophie théorique
mais bien une philosophie pratique
C’est à la fois une philosophie et une psychologie
notre vie n’est pas éternelle
nous devons accepter la mort, nous devons accepter notre propre mort. Alors Epicure disais
apprendre à vivre c’est apprendre à mourir
et la philosophie c’est tout le travail d’acceptation de la mort
Mais ce n’est pas l’accepter comme quelque chose de triste, de regrettable
C’est l’accepter comme une nécessité
c’est l’accepter comme une loi de la nature
Et c’est seulement à partir du moment où je l’accepte profondément comme une loi de la nature
que je peux m’émanciper
de la tristesse, du chagrin, de la souffrance que cette idée normalement véhicule
Si vous pensez l’instant
vous essayez d’imaginer
à quel âge, en quel lieu, en quelles circonstances
Est ce vous allez mourir d’une mort naturelle, est ce que vous allez mourir dans votre sommeil ?
est ce que vous allez mourir d’un accident de voiture, d’une maladie incurable ?
Bien tout de suite ce qui va vous envahir c’est un sentiment d’angoisse,
et ce sentiment d’angoisse pour les stoïciens il est la preuve que d’une certaine manière vous n’avez pas accepté l’idée de la mort
Alors on retrouve beaucoup cette idée que ce soit chez les stoïciens ou chez les épicuriens
qui est de dire que : la mort n’est rien
La mort n’est rien pourquoi ? bien parce que l’on vit, bien la mort n’est pas là
Et lorsqu’on meurt et bien on est plus là pour souffrir
Donc finalement on ne rencontre jamais la mort
La mort nous emporte
mais en un claquement de doigt qui fait que on n’a pas le temps de la voir
Donc l’angoisse de la mort c’est l’angoisse d’une idée
et non pas l’angoisse d’une réalité
c’est l’angoisse d’une projection mentale
Et c’est là qu’on commence à s’approcher un petit peu plus du noyau de la philosophie stoïcienne
qui est le rôle de la projection imaginaire
qui fait que l’individu n’est jamais totalement dans sa réalité présente
On n’est jamais vraiment dans l’instant présent si on peur dire.
On est toujours dans l’anticipation du futur
ou dans la nostalgie du passé
mais au final on n’est jamais réellement dans le présent
Le problème de ces projections
c’est qu’elles font naître en nous des émotions,
des émotions que les stoïciens appelaient des passions
Donc c’est l’ancien terme pour parler des émotions, alors passion en Grec ça se dit pathos
pathos qui veut dire souffrance
Et la passion c’est ce face à quoi nous sommes passifs
c’est ce que nous subissons
La peur, le regret, la jalousie, l’envie, la colère
tout ça ce sont des émotions, ce sont des passions
Mais ce des choses qui sont d’abord des créations de notre esprit
et c’est la preuve que nous n’acceptons pas l’existence telle qu’elle est
J’ai pris l’exemple de l’angoisse de la mort mais on pourrait prendre un tas d’autres exemples
Si par exemple, je suis jaloux de mon voisin, je suis jaloux de mon voisin parce qu’il a une plus belle voiture que moi ou
parce qu’il a une plus belle femme que moi, des plus beaux enfants que moi, peu importe
Bien, cette jalousie c’est une projection de mon esprit
C'est-à-dire que si mon voisin n’avait pas tous ce que je n’ai pas
je ne serai pas malheureux
Donc c’est parce que mon voisin a ce que je n’ai pas que j’ai cette frustration qui se traduit pas la jalousie
Mais dans ce cas là ce n’est pas mon voisin qui est responsable, c’est moi
C’est moi qui laisse cette pensée et les émotions qui découlent de cette pensée
c’est moi qui laisse ces émotions prendre le dessus
Prendre le dessus sur moi, prendre le dessus sur mon état affectif
Donc j’en suis responsable, donc ça dépend de moi
Et là on en arrive à cette idée des stoïciens qui est que je ne dois pas être affecté par ce qui ne dépend pas de moi
D’accord donc premier constat, il y a ce qui dépend de moi, il y a ce qu’il n’en dépend pas
Deuxième constat je ne dois pas être affecté par ce qu’il ne dépend pas de moi
Je disais tout à l’heure que la peur de la mort pour les stoïciens c’était une aberration logique
mais en fait pour les stoïciens toutes émotions est une aberration logique
Pour une raison simple qui est que une émotion ne résout pas le problème qui en est la cause
Alors en réalité pour les stoïciens la cause de nos émotions c’est nous même
Mais nous, nous identifions spontanément la cause de nos émotions à quelque chose d’extérieur à nous
Si je suis en colère ce n’est pas de ma faute c’est parce qu’on ma rendu en colère, c’est parce qu’on m’a mis en colère
Pour les stoïciens ça c’est de la foutaise.
Si on est en colère c’est parce qu’on n’arrive pas à maîtriser nos émotions
et l’autre n’est qu’un prétexte
pour justifier notre colère, c'est-à-dire pour justifier notre incapacité à maitriser nos émotions
Nos émotions nous en sommes responsables
une preuve de ça c’est qu’il y a des personnes qui arrivent très bien à gérer leurs émotions
Il y a des personnes qui arrivent à ne pas se laisser perturber ou affecter par des événements extérieurs
y compris des événements qui peuvent apparaître comme extrêmement graves et pénibles
Et d’ailleurs on dit de ces personnes qu’elles savent rester stoïques
Stoïque dans le langage courant ça signifie impassible, impassible, sans passions
c’est une forme d’indifférence
mais qui n’est pas une indifférence disons liée à une absence de conscience au contraire
C’est une indifférence maîtrisée, c’est une indifférence assumée
puisqu’elle correspond à la conscience qu’il y a des choses qui ne dépendent pas de nous
Et les stoïciens nous disent : pourquoi être affecté parce qu’il ne dépend pas de toi ?
ça ne résoudra pas le problème
la colère ne va pas faire disparaître les raisons de la colère
La jalousie ne va pas faire disparaître les raison de la jalousie
Pour les stoïciens les émotions c’est un petit peu la chaleur que produit une énergie que nous n’arrivons pas à canaliser
Alors on a besoin d'extérioriser cette énergie par une émotion
mais ça ne résout pas le problème
Si je me cogne le genou contre le coin de ma table basse
bien j’aurais beau insulter ma table basse ou lui taper dessus, ça ne va pas faire disparaître ma douleur… quoi que
Ça va me permettre de dépenser l’énergie qui est due à ma douleur et à la colère qui résulte de cette douleur
Si je regarde une émission de télé avec pour invité principal B.H.L
bien j’aurais beau l’insulter et jeter ma télécommande à travers ma télé ça ne résoudra rien
Donc ce que nous disent les stoïciens c’est que il ne sert à rien d’être dans l’émotion
et que à travers nos émotions en réalité on masque notre incapacité à accepter le monde tel qui l’est
C’est pour ça qu’une autre citation des stoïciens c’est de dire :
ne cherche pas à changer la réalité
mais à changer le point de vue que tu as sur la réalité
Alors là évidemment on va se dire mais qu’est ce que c’est que cette philosophie ?
Qui est finalement une philosophie de la soumission, une philosophie de la passivité
C’est légitime de se dire ça
Si j’accepte tout
c’est une forme de renoncement, ça revient à dire je dois accepter les injustices
je dois accepter par exemple que l’on puisse me mentir, que l’on puisse me voler, que l’on puisse me tromper
Je dois accepter l’immoralité de mon voisin
parce que les stoïciens me disent que si je n’accepte pas et bien je suis dans la folie
Oui et non
n’oubliez pas que les stoïciens font la différence entre ce qui dépend de moi et ce qui ne dépend pas de moi
Il y a des choses sur lesquelles je peux avoir un Control et les stoïciens nous disent bien :
donne moi la force de changer ce qui peut l’être
Donc la première difficulté es t de savoir ce qui peut être changé
et d’agir à mon niveau sur ce qui peut être changé
Mais je ne dois pas avoir des prétentions qui sont au delà de mes moyens
je ne dois pas
penser que je suis capable de révolutionner le monde tout seul avec mes petits bras
Je dois accepter que seul
les changements que je peux apporter
les transformations que je peux opérer sur le monde
et bien elles seront à l’image de mes capacités
c'est-à-dire pas grand-chose
Relativement au monde pas grand-chose
Mais j’ai le choix entre faire ce que je peux faire et laisser tomber en disant après tout ça sert à rien
J’ai le chois, je peux accepter de renoncer et de me dire à quoi bon
Mais dans ce cas là pour les stoïciens je ne fais pas ce qui dépend de moi
j’abandonne, je renonce, je démissionne
Mais pourquoi ?
Parce que je ne supporte pas l’idée de ne pas avoir plus d’emprise sur le monde
Donc en fait
je renonce par égo
je renonce parce que je dis à moi tout seul je ne pourrai pas opérer les changements que je souhaite opérer
D’accord, mais ça c’est un raisonnement qui est dicté par l’égo
qui est dicté par l’émotion
qui est dicté par le sentiment et le désir de toute puissance
Mais là pour les stoïciens on est toujours dans l’aberration
Donc pour les stoïciens on agit sur le périmètre sur lequel on peut agir
Et on ne se préoccupe pas du reste
On ne soucis pas du reste parce que le reste ne nous appartient pas
Parce que le reste appartient au monde
Et que le monde poursuit son chemin sans nous
Nous faisons parti du monde
nous déposons sur lui notre empreinte
mais nous n’en sommes pas propriétaire
Il appartient à nous en tant qu’individu de faire des choses dont nous sommes capables
il ne nous appartient pas en tant qu’individu d’agir à la place des autres
Donc plutôt que d’une philosophie du renoncement moi je parlerai plutôt d’une philosophie de la lucidité
Je pense et là c’est un jugement tout à fait personnel
, que les personnes qui accomplissent de grandes choses
sont des personnes qui ne se soucis pas de ce qu’elles ne sont pas capables de faire
Ce sont des personnes qui se soucient exclusivement de ce qu’elles sont capables de faire
Avoir des rêves inatteignables c’est le meilleur moyen de ne jamais en réaliser un seul
Désirer l’impossible c’est le meilleur moyen de rester dans l’inaction
donc dans la passivité et donc dans la frustration qui accompagne nécessairement cette passivité
La philosophie des stoïciens est une philosophie pratique parce que c’est une philosophie qui nous pousse à mettre nos actes en conformité avec nos pensées
On disait tout à l’heure si j’évolue dans des émotions telles que la colère, la jalousie, le ressentiment
mes actions porteront la marque de ces émotions
Au contraire si j’agis dans l’enthousiasme, si j’agis dans une sorte de gaité
de joie inconditionnelle, de joie qui n’a pas besoin de raison d’être
et bien pour les stoïciens je suis beaucoup plus libre car je ne dépends pas de mes émotions
car je ne dépends pas d’une ambition irréaliste. Je ne dépends pas de l’illusion
Pour les stoïciens nos émotions nous rendent esclaves
c’est très clair
Nos émotions nous empêchent de voir et de comprendre la réalité telle qu’elle est
C’est comme un filtre qu’on mettrait entre nous et la réalité et qui du même coup déformerai cette réalité à nos yeux
Si je parts du principe que le monde a existé avant moi et qu’il existera toujours après moi
et bien d’un ça relativise ma capacité d’action et de transformation de ce monde
Mais ça ne veut pas dire que je ne suis capable de rien
Ça veut dire que j’ai conscience des limites dans lesquelles je peux agir
Les émotions nous rendent esclaves puisque par définition nous ne choisissons pas d’avoir des émotions
En fait pour les stoïciens il serait plus juste de dire que :
Nous subissons nos émotions parce que nous ne faisons pas l’effort qu’il faut pour les maîtriser
Les stoïciens pensent que le but de l’existence humaine c’est d’atteindre le bonheur et la sagesse, puisque pour eux la sagesse c’est la condition du bonheur
Et la sagesse c’est lié aussi à la connaissance, à la compréhension
Je comprends le monde, je comprends la manière dont il fonctionne, je l’accepte et parce que je l’accepte, je peux être heureux
Il y a une phrase de Sartre
pour le coup qui résume assez bien le point de vue des stoïciens
qui est de dire : « L’important n’est pas ce qu’on a fait de nous, mais ce qu’on fait de ce qu’on a fait de nous »
Ça veut dire quoi ? bien ça veut dire que nous avons tous un caractère ou un tempérament, même si
il convient de distinguer ces deux notions
Et nous sommes tous plus ou moins enclin à ressentir, à éprouver des émotions, des passions
Ça, ça ne dépend pas entièrement de nous, il y a des gens qui sont plutôt colérique, il y a des gens qui sont plutôt calme
il y a des gens qui sont plutôt inquiet, d’autre qui sont plutôt paisible. C’est vrai.
Mais rien ne nous empêches de travailler sur ça
rien ne nous empêches de prendre conscience de ce caractère qui est le notre
t de travailler à le changer puisque ça c’est dans nos possibilités
Et pour changer ça et bien ça passe par une démarche de compréhension du monde et de ses lois
La vision stoïcienne du monde est une vision déterministe
Ca veut dire que pour les stoïciens tout ce qui arrive dans l’univers arrive pour une certaine raison
alors pour une certaine raison ça ne signifie pas qu’il y a des Dieux qui tirent des ficelles et qui nous poussent à agir dans un sens plutôt que dans un autre
On pourrait le résumer comme ça mais ce serait un peu trop simpliste
Et puis surtout il y en a qui dirait : Ah c’est une vision encore religieuse, ça ne m’intéresse pas, c’est pas pour moi. Non c’est pas aussi simple
Ça consiste à dire que quand quelque chose se produit, c’est qu’il y a des causes à cet événement
Aucun événement ne se produit sans causes
Donc quand on veut dire que tout à une raison, en fait on veut dire que tout à une cause
Mais le mot raison est intéressant, on verra pourquoi.
Tout ce qui arrive à une cause ou à un ensemble de causes
ce qui fait qu’on peut expliquer tout ce qui arrive
Expliquer ne signifie pas accepter automatiquement
et expliquer ne signifie pas non plus justifier au sens de légitimer
sur le plan normatif, sur le plan moral
Par exemple si un homme commet un crime
on peut expliquer son crime par un diagnostic médical, psychologique, psychiatrique
On dira par exemple que c’est quelqu’un qui a subit lui-même des violences extrêmes qui est devenu ce qu’on appelle un psychopathe et qu’il est passé à l’acte
Bien, mais ça ne justifie pas son geste au sens où ça ne l’excuse pas
Pour les stoïciens cette distinction entre expliquer et excuser, elle n’a pas vraiment lieu d’être
Quand je dis que ça n’a pas lieu d’être, évidemment qu’elle a lieu d’être dans le cadre social
Mais elle n’a pas lieu d’être dans le sens où si une chose arrive c’est que de toute façon elle avait des raisons d’arriver. C’est que de toute façon elle a des causes puisque rien n’arrive sans causes
Tout ce qui arrive est un effet de causes qui le précède
Donc si on était capable du point de vue de notre connaissance d’identifier toutes les causes de ce qui arrive
et bien on s’apercevrait que tout est normal
Et je devrai s dire plutôt que tout est normal, et je devrais dire plutôt que tout est normal, c’est un terme qui prête toujours à polémique. Tout est logique, tout est rationnel,
tout est rationnel
La raison englobe tout ce qui l’est logique de comprendre
et si quelque chose se produit
c’est que cette chose avait des causes, et ces causes sont compréhensibles
Je ne dis pas que nous sommes capables d’identifier toutes les causes de ce qui arrive, mais on est capable de savoir que ces causes existent
Je vais prendre l’exemple de la coïncidence, la fameuse coïncidence
Vous rencontrez quelqu’un ça faisait un moment que vous ne l’aviez pas vu
et vous le rencontrez dans un contexte totalement improbable
C’est pas possible qu’on se rencontre ici, là, maintenant. Quelle coïncidence.
La coïncidence ou plutôt le sentiment de la coïncidence extraordinaire
c’est quelque chose qu’on a tous déjà vécu
mais qui pour les stoïciens correspond seulement à notre point de vue individuel
Et si on voulait être un peu méchant on dirait qui correspond à notre point de vue d’ignorant
D’ignorant parce qu’en fait nous sommes surpris de quelque chose quand nous n’en connaissons pas les causes
C’est ça en fait la surprise
on ignore les causes, mais si on avait connu les causes de Evènement avant que cet événement se produise
on aurait été capable de l’anticiper, on aurait été capable de le prédire comme étant la conséquence logique, rationnelle, nécessaire de ces causes
Je vais prendre une image. Imaginez que vous êtes dans le ciel et que vous avez vu sur une ville
vous voyez toutes les rues entre les immeubles et donc vous voyez toutes les personnes qui s’y déplacent
Et donc vous êtes capable de voir à quel moment deux personnes vont se croiser à un angle de rue parce que vous avez le point de vue omniscient, vous êtes au dessus
et donc vous voyez la rencontre avant que la rencontre n’est lieu
Pour vous rien n’est surprenant, mais pour les individus qui se rencontrent et qui se rentrent dedans au coin de la rue c’est extraordinaire
Donc on est dans une question de point de vue en fait, la surprise, l’étonnement, la coïncidence, le sentiment de coïncidence c’est un sentiment qui est propre à l’individu
Mais si l’individu était capable de s’élever d’un point de vue rationnel c'est-à-dire d’un point de vue objectif
du point de vue omniscient, et bien en fait il ne serait pas surpris, il s’y attendrait
Pour les stoïciens rien de ce qui arrive n’est étonnant
Parce qu’ils adoptent ce point de vue omniscient, parce qu’ils savent que lorsque quelque chose se produit c’est qu’il y avait des raisons que ça se produise
Et c’est ça le déterminisme
C’est le fait de se dire que tout ce qui arrive est l’effet nécessaire, c'est-à-dire fatal de causes qui précède cet évènement
Pour les stoïciens l’univers est totalement rationnel. S’il est rationnel, il obéit aux lois de la logique, il est donc compréhensible dans sa totalité
Si le réel est rationnel, si le réel est logique, l’homme doit dans la mesure du possible se conformer à ce modèle de rationalité
L’homme en tant que parti de l’univers doit chercher à se comporter comme cet univers
Plus il se comportera comme l’univers c'est-à-dire de manière rationnelle et logique, et moins il sera soumis à la souffrance, à la frustration, à la tristesse, bref, moins il sera soumis à ses émotions
Plus il se rapprochera de ce modèle de rationalité et plus il sera libre. Et plus il sera libre, plus il sera heureux.
Le bonheur c’est lorsque je deviens capable de ne plus dépendre de mes émotions qui sont comme des sangsues qui m’empêchent de déployer mon potentiel rationnel
Alors évidemment on pourra dire mais qu’est ce que c’est que ce modèle totalement inhumain ?
Oui effectivement on peut considérer que c’est quelque chose de complètement inaccessible à l’être humain, cette capacité d’objectivité absolue qui fait qu’on ne va plus dépendre de ses émotions
On peut le considérer, mais les stoïciens s’en foutent
Les stoïciens se disent est ce qu’on est capable d’aller vers cet idéal ? Est ce qu’on est capable de se déprendre de l'influence nos émotions ? Oui, on est capable, on en est capable
Mais c’est pas facile, évidemment que c’est pas facile. Mais les stoïciens n’ont jamais dit que la sagesse était quelque chose de facile
Les philosophes d’une manière générale n’ont jamais dit que le bonheur ou la connaissance était des choses faciles
Ils disent c’est possible, c’est faisable, la preuve que c’est faisable puisque on peut en former le projet
Donc oui on peut se débarrasser, on peut vaincre nos émotions
et c’est par ce travail de combat contre nos émotions qu’on peut aller vers la sagesse et le bonheur
Le bonheur pour les stoïciens ce n’est en aucun cas la satisfaction de ses désirs.
Pour eux satisfaire ses désirs c’est le contraire du bonheur
Alors si vous m’avez suivi jusque là vous devriez deviner pourquoi
le bonheur c’est le contraire de la satisfaction du désir ?
Et bien parce que le désir c’est quelque chose qui ne dépend pas de nous
Le désir c’est, un sentiment qui nous habite, un sentiment qui peut même devenir physique
et qui vient manifester notre manque d’un objet extérieur
Je désire quelque chose que je n’ai pas par définition. Mais lorsque je le désire je prouve que je dépends de cet objet
en tout cas je prouve que mon bonheur dépend de cet objet
Et je vais spontanément associer mon bonheur à l’acquisition de l’objet que je désire
Ça pour les stoïciens c’est une illusion totale
Et d’ailleurs je pense que chacun d’entre vous, vous pouvez en faire l’expérience
Si vous désirez quelque chose, vous avez envie d’une cigarette par exemple, comme moi en ce moment
Bien vous allez fumer votre cigarette et lorsque vous l’aurez terminé, il ne va pas falloir longtemps avant d’avoir envie de la prochaine
Donc vous n’aurez pas tué votre désir au sens où vous ne l’aurez pas satisfait
Donc la cigarette que je suis entrain de fumer actuellement, elle ne me rend pas heureux
elle comble un désir, elle comble un manque mais qui ne manquera pas de resurgir dans quelques temps
Donc le bonheur ce n’est pas obtenir quelque chose qu’on désire
Le bonheur c’est ne plus dépendre de ses désirs
Le bonheur c’est ne plus désirer. Je désire quelque chose lorsque je suis en manque
Fatalement. Lorsque je ne suis plus en manque, lorsque je suis comblé, bien je ne désire plus
On peut être heureux dans la maladie, on peut être heureux dans la solitude
on peut même être heureux dans la souffrance physique
D’ailleurs ça me fait penser à une autre citation d’Epictète. Epictète était un esclave
Puisqu'il y avait des esclaves qui étaient stoïciens et vous allez me dire ah bien il valait mieux être stoïcien quand on était esclave, ça aidait à supporter
C’est vrai mais il y avait des empereurs qui étaient stoïciens comme Marc Aurèle par exemple
Epictète rapporte à un moment donné une anecdote
il disait qu’on essayait de lui casser le bras
en lui faisant une clé quoi
en le tordant
Et il avait dit, tu vas finir par me le casser ce bras
Et puis son bras se casse et il dit : « ah bien tu vois, je te l’avais bien dit »
Donc c’est une citation un peu amusante pour dire bien que
le stoïcien total, le stoïcien accompli c’est celui qui est capable d’être dans la pure constatation sans aucunes émotions et sans aucunes expressions de souffrance
Alors oui on peut considérer que c’est un idéal un peu difficile à atteindre mais je ferai remarquer que certaines personnes humaines
de notre époque sont capables d’atteindre ce genre d’état, ce qu’on appelle les yogis
qui sont capables d’endurer une souffrance absolument intolérable
par un détachement de l’esprit
Donc les stoïciens préconisent effectivement ce genre de pratique notamment la pratique de la méditation qui est un canal vers la sagesse
Au sens où la méditation nous permet de nous concentrer sur notre conscience plutôt que sur notre corps
Alors je vais essayer de conclure
les stoïciens nous disent qu’il y a ce qui dépend de nous et ce qui ne dépend pas de nous
Et qui ne dépend que de nous de ne plus être dépendant de ce qui ne dépend pas de nous.
Pour les stoïciens l’univers obéit à des lois, des lois implacables
Ce qu’on pourrait appeler les lois de la fatalité, mais la fatalité n’a pas chez les stoïciens une connotation négative
D’ailleurs si on veut être un peut honnête c’est surtout dans nos sociétés contemporaines que la fatalité a une connotation négative
puisque on considère que du moment où il y a fatalité, il y a absence de libre arbitre
Mais pour les stoïciens c'est pas du tout ça
Le libre arbitre existe pour les stoïciens au sens où il dépend de nous
de nous de ne pas nous affecter, de ne pas nous émouvoir de la nécessité implacable du monde
Il dépend de nous et il ne dépend que de nous d’être heureux dans la situation qui est la notre
Ce qui n’implique pas que nous devons être passif face à l’existence, face à ce qui arrive
ce qui implique seulement que nous devons faire preuve de discernement, de lucidité
sur ce qui peut être changer
sur les raisons de changer ce qui doit l’être
et sur les moyens employés pour changer ce qui doit l’être.
Le stoïcisme c’est une philosophie pratique
d’ailleurs aujourd’hui le stoïcisme s’est d’ailleurs converti dans les techniques de développement personnel
Je n’ai rien contre les techniques de développement personnel
je pense simplement que elles sont un aspect superficiel de quelque chose de beaucoup plus profond qui est une philosophie à par entière
On ne peut pas simplement prendre l’aspect pratique de la philosophie stoïcienne et dire que ça suffit. Non.
Puisque pour les stoïciens cette capacité à maitriser ses émotions, cette capacité à devenir le capitaine sur le paquebot de notre existence
cette capacité là ne peut être que le résultat d’une démarche de compréhension du monde
Comprendre le monde  ne signifie pas l’accepter
mais il est impossible de l’accepter si on ne cherche pas à le comprendre
Comprendre le monde c’est comprendre que ce qui arrive a des raisons d’arriver
Et que ce qui est, est le seul arbitre
Je peux déplorer à titre individuel une situation mais il n’empêche que cette situation a une raison d’être
Et peu importe si je n’en comprends pas le sens,
peu importe si je n’en comprends pas les causes. Il n’empêche que cette situation est là et que je ne peux que l’accepter
Il ne sert à rien de résister face à ce qui est implacable
il ne sert à rien de s’énerver parce qu’il pleut ou parce qu’il fait froid
Ça n’arrangera rien quoi que si je m’énerve je peux au moins me réchauffer, c’est déjà ça
Mais si j’accepte qui m’est apriori désagréable et bien ça cesse d’être désagréable
Personnellement j’utilise beaucoup le stoïcisme quand je lis les commentaires sous mes vidéos
Je me dis, bon, il y a une raison à ça donc j’accepte
C’est très pratique le stoïcisme et surtout c’est une philosophie qui agit sur nous lorsqu’on en lit des fragments
Je vous conseille vraiment de lire les « Pensées » de Marc Aurèle, « Pensées pour moi-même »
Et vous allez vous apercevoir qu’en lisant vous avez une sensation étrange d’apaisement au fur et à mesure de la lecture
comme si l’évidence logique implacable de ce que vous lisez vous équilibrez, vous alignez à l’intérieur.
Et lorsque vous êtes dans cet état d’esprit, lorsque vous êtes dans cet état de neutralité par rapport à vos émotions
vous vous rendez compte qu’effectivement tout est justifié d’un point de vue rationnel en tout cas, tout est justifié
Et que si la vie ne se limite pas à la raison et bien il n’y a pas de raison que la vie soit une longue succession de souffrance.
Merci à vous.